all right in Idaho is Lewis hi Luis how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve what's up hey I got a real
simple question uh my wife and I are
fairly new to the program but I had some
family the other day talking about how
foolish it was not to have a credit card
because then if we'd ever want to buy a
house or something take out a mortgage
that we would have no credit no and I
remember I've heard you talk about it
before I just want to be able to explain
to them that if they say it's impossible
to take out a mortgage without a credit
score well that's just somebody that
doesn't know what they're talking about
I'm sure they're broke people but
they're in your family we all got people
like that in our family that are experts
on something that they don't know
nothing about so if you go to churchill
mortgage or other mortgage brokers that
actually know how to do what's called
manual underwriting where they don't
require a credit score but they do
require that they verify your job and
they verify your down payment is in the
actual bank and they do what's manually
underwrite it instead of just depending
on the credit score to give you the loan
then you can get a you can get a
mortgage loan at no extra charge no
extra thing at all no problems at all
except it's a little bit more hassle to
do manual underwriting and so it's done
everyday churchill's done it for years
we thought we've told people to do this
for years they do it all the time you
know if you're self-employed you have to
have two years of tax returns and if
you're self-employed you can't get an
FHA loan now or you have you know so
there's some of these loans they just
won't write them but but other than that
you know it's it's a very normal process
it's kind of how mortgage is used to be
done before the FICO score like when I
got my real estate license in the 70s
it's how we used to do mortgages you
actually had to go in and prove you had
an income and a job and you had to prove
you know that you pay your bills on time
they pulled a copy of your credit bureau
and looked at your past even if there
was no credit score there's stuff on
your credit bureau from your past but if
you have no open accounts for six months
to a year no open accounts with no
balances
kind then eventually you're gonna have
no credit score which is what I have I
had a credit score in 20 years - zero
and it's working out for me pretty good
this is the Dave Ramsey show